[Music]
and hold it in this Oh what lately I've
been training myself to not pee so like
I just hold it in like a [ __ ]
so you get a UTI I have [ __ ] hurts
man but then I'm like peeing every hour
and [ __ ] so I got like I'm just gonna
hold it in why are you looking in the
mirror there's something like I have to
pee so bad what benefit are you going on
like a cruise or something soon you know
I just don't wanna like constantly have
to pee like I'm driving and I'm like off
here I go again I gotta pee I think I'm
too used to having access to a bathroom
so my body's just used to peeing peeing
peeing and supposed to be nowadays it's
modern society right if you're drinking
enough water you're gonna pee once an
hour I drink a lot of what's good prior
to be drinking a lot of water I didn't
have to pee much at all but now I pee
all the [ __ ] time it's like
impossible but it's also satisfied to me
that when I do load up and then it's
just that's the morning peace yep I
remember one night in the first day I
realized I was a man is taking a pee
that was as long as my dad used to take
a pee yeah cuz I could hear my dad in
there I'm like [ __ ] four and a half
minutes long like holy [ __ ]
I can read like one of my little kid
books like in that amount of time your
dad goes in there with like Pandora and
he plays a song to pee too and then he
outlast the song he pees for a long time
to see I could do that now but but I
didn't think it was possible
I've been brewing I was a kid I was
bored really late one time and I had to
pee so bad I was like oh I know I mean a
people a long time so what I did is I
held my breath and I peed longer than
what I could hold my breath okay
independent you challenged yourself
you got a pee longer you gotta [ __ ] it
you know what happened the other day
this is so [ __ ] crazy oh is it
something we need to talk
behind closed doors you shouldn't hear
it first I don't think so oh man [ __ ] no
it's nothing crazy so you know in the
middle night [ __ ] blood right what what
the red is blood so at night I've been
not changing my tight guy's diaper and
stuff so I got to get up and that's what
I'm getting up I'm just like [ __ ] it
I'll just pee anyways and usually the
toilet seat is left up so I'm just
peeing you know I just hear the water
like I'm tired I'm just like okay cool
are you peeing on the cover the other
day I was peeing is why it is the piece
splattering on my leg shut up and then
all that what the [ __ ] going on this I
just keep moving around
I know I'll find the water you wouldn't
look no and I turn on the light and then
the basically you are a laser beam
you're shooting at Captain America
shield is going everywhere were you
wouldn't meet how did you clean the
toilet seat I was so young what always
says that you were like a son there's
even affect you it affected everyone
else in the [ __ ] room alright is your
[ __ ] child you have to clean that
[ __ ] up with paper towels and stuff I
just tissue paper it smells like piss
that's why I even told them like we have
to hire professional cleaners cuz it's
your stupid Alex I've appeared on the
toilet seat you've been doing
bro well here's the story
submitted by best song of all time it's
hard to say miss purple rain to make
purple way a suspected drug dealer who
went 47 days without pooping to hide
evidence is freed what you die right do
this what 7 days you should be shut up
how did did he [ __ ] sweat his [ __ ]
off now if you could legitimate that
people used to die in like internment
camps from not [ __ ] over like long
periods of time how could they confirm
you think wait do you just start
smelling like [ __ ] after a while
god this was like just coming out of you
like yea comes out of your pores yeah
yeah I'd free the guy - that's Talent
you yeah so this guy he was a suspected
drug dealer so when the police we're
gonna pull him over he ended up taking
off and then they the police caught up
to him that's when they realized that he
ingested something and so they took him
into custody
and they waited out this whole time for
him to poop like they fed him he was
drinking laxatives I mean I don't know -
like what it could just uh [ __ ] x-ray
and they would have seen it in there
right yeah I was wondering the same
thing but they must have laws against
that or something cuz they were they had
to wait and have a warrant to go cuz X
lakhs well do it quite well yeah they
should have just fed them some X legs
well maybe it's against some sort of
rule that it was a tiny law article 2
section 3 Constitution what happened in
London they don't have any Mexican
Street food that's the problem because
that would have fixed it real quick for
sure that's not boys delicious cheese
butter just take him into a Taco Bell
mum smell it and then go and your
children you shouldn't you should have
gave them some coffee and cigarettes
even broken British record for spending
the most days in custody while police
wait for him to poop on drugs - every
days - how much did he [ __ ] when he came
out though that must have been
ridiculous probably dead man is that
his record does guinness track it
because they tracked literally
everything yeah I know like what I go
when I went camping like out Tahoe
they'll be like some disgusting ass
porta-potties and for a couple days like
my body just would [ __ ] and then what I
went home ridiculous dude I won't even
sit on a airplane I won't do it I don't
care I've done some naughty flights to
like from you can't hold it because if I
always got the verge of [ __ ] in my
pants always right now like could you
[ __ ] right now if I commanded you know
but I've started and accidentally shot
Dookie out couple times and that just
that was like oh I thought I was gonna
be a fart like I had no idea man you're
just full of [ __ ] I know and I had a
problem with [ __ ] when I was in high
school - yeah absolutely
dude III was like constipated for like a
couple weeks so I this guy going through
that is [ __ ] crazy there's been a lot
of pain huh yeah but I also barely ate -
so I did I didn't I didn't eat fiber and
all this stuff so I have [ __ ] problems
and I had to get those [ __ ] Bebe's
like what do you call it those sonograms
or whatever when they go up the shape
break up all that [ __ ] man they rubbed
your [ __ ] and they like they put the
cool Joe on no they x-ray your
intestines and [ __ ] and then I saw my
Dookie just stuck there Wow yeah and I
take all these pills man I would sit on
the toilet like cry my eyes out cuz of
the [ __ ] pain I couldn't [ __ ] [ __ ]
in your city on toilet praying to poo
yeah the opposite happened after that
why just everybody like everyday Leakey
but every morning guarantee I'm walking
to school and I [ __ ] walk back home
cuz I gotta take a donkey butt yeah that
sounds like a like a children's book
like one of those little diesel leaky
but yeah the leaky but by dr. Seuss yeah
the little Calla pillar that [ __ ] have
you guys ever take like tasted or had
like medical grade like laxative before
no it is it is it is destructive
it is on d-struct it what does it do I
mean it's so like I did you get stomach
cramps so it's like this so I got a
regular laxative will hit gradually yeah
you know so like I'll take X lakhs or I
haven't taken in a while but I had it
and then like three four hours later
you'll feel like okay I gotta take a
[ __ ] and it goes a medical relax it just
hits like a [ __ ] bomb so you'll take
it and then you'll sit in the office
they'll make you sit there for a while
right and nobody it'll probably kick in
in about five minutes
am I gonna kick in wait a little longer
I was like I'm fine
I stood up shut just jet it and it just
everything came out it is destructive
alright next who was addicted to
laxatives what does it taste good Wow
she was just [ __ ] a lot I didn't
know cuz she kept it from me and I ended
up finding out about it later like the
whole place felt like [ __ ] yeah no no
because it was just like she kept the
laughs it was like out of the usual
areas that I would see things that's a
lot of lighting a dicks a lot of models
do that like before their shoot so like
a few days before the interest latter
tummy yep bunch of laxatives drive
themselves out so they look really good
on pictures and the only time I ever
took laxatives was for a powerlifting me
like I already did like the sign I
already peed already [ __ ] I'm like how
am I going to lose weight on my [ __ ] and
I'll see if I can get in with reserve
[ __ ] out and then I took uh I took the
team you [ __ ] have reserved [ __ ]
everyone has reserved [ __ ] their
intestine data that I would drink is
very long mm-hmm and it starts off with
just like farts I'm always laying in bed
it's like was it toilet seat up or down
not much tumbling bed and then it's just
like and then I will start feeling
oh [ __ ] little nuggets come in like
Foreman and then and then it came out
and then I wasn't that much I think mine
normally I'm a pretty good [ __ ] of [ __ ]
do you ever get bored Bart and you you
close your eyes and try to find the
toilet so you can [ __ ] let me know if
you find me I don't do that aboard of
though let me tell you this crazy story
right so I'll take this [ __ ] in the dark
right and then every time I shed I table
with higher and higher and higher
I just kept filling it all my budgets
right across my butt yep and I just kept
moving around by the hole here well I'll
wait to find out with
my ears first what are they well they
give me these for Judaism maniac didn't
you let go didn't you go to their
wedding on the toilet or something oh
yeah guess what I'm doing right now I'm
taking a [ __ ] little speech oh my god
forget it no what's cuz I mean you gave
a speech right and then I listened to
your gurus you're the echoey voice my
gosh the cuckoo
I would never push during talking oh
that's nice yes I would never push
during wedding manager ever yes anyway
this dude here they're saying that they
took him to the hospital because he need
like you know for ethical responsibility
of them Oh 47 days or like I guess right
where they have 46 days who were they on
46 days the room just smelled like far
he had it that long
man I'm surprised he didn't [ __ ] in his
sleep I know I'm thinking like he might
have [ __ ] when no one was looking cuz
there was two guys there saying that
there was two police officers that were
keeping an eye an eye on him yeah but
I'm like there during the exchange
probably [ __ ] it and [ __ ] do it under
the seat or something I also love the
idea that this is all just for wheat
yeah cuz in America it probably was yeah
well there's an class aim drug I don't
know
hey I'm sure weeds of Class A drugs
trust me what the [ __ ] is with all the
weed hate man it's crazy
who the [ __ ] cares like they're cracking
down even worse on weed now oh really
yeah
federally oh it's the twenty some money
or something I don't know it's just
bizarre is held to me I thought we were
getting past this [ __ ] and then all of a
sudden it's like back in the weeds they
treat weed like it's crackin Asia yeah
it's like it's like possible a death
yeah well Class A drugs in the UK's
ecstasy LSD heroin cocaine crack magic
mushrooms injected a Mensa cementum well
that's like us too yeah I guess weed
isn't
that's good that's a relief
[Music]
[Music]
you